that's not the plan
um
I just saw recently maybe two days ago
she had a spill Krishan had a spill
she's pregnant with your with your child
she had a spill at the club she fell
yeah
um hey man I don't know I was just gonna
say that personally I don't think she
should be in the club this late in the
game I don't think she I thought she was
rolling up on IV live it's not about the
money it's not about now she just kind
of she just kind of lost in the
the hype of social media well I was
gonna say obviously you're she's
carrying your child that's your that's
your child right so how worried are you
about the safety of the womb the safety
of them I can't I can't worry until this
is it's on my plate you know right in
her belly when she has it I hope she
watches enough wises up and like realize
that every penny is not worth
are you trying safety like like what's
the do you have you even put your mind
around the custody situation no no no
I'm gonna let her be a mom I'm Gonna
Hurt yeah try to be a mom and let her do
her best at it and then if she doesn't
succeed then I'll step in but
man [__] it's hard to push the baby all
right it hurts
more than that it hurts you you spent
nine months with a baby in you and then
you push it out it hurts it's like kind
of yo yo the ball's in your court I feel
like I mean the balls in the balls in
whoever's carrying the court I mean
whoever's carrying it from day one
though like I'm saying you as a mother
you carrying it you nurturing it when
you pushing it out you have another
story a lot of the work you guys have
two kids together yeah a boy and a girl
and I've seen the whole process it's a
lot of work it looks very painful
and if you're going through that you you
gotta you gotta be down for that you
know yeah I was gonna say like if it
gets to the point where you're like I
got I gotta take care of the kids oh
yeah I'm gonna do what I have to do but
I'm gonna let her be a mom are you
babysitting
I'm not babysitting I'm not babysitting
no she's not babysitting but yeah
I don't know responsible yeah I'm
yes I'm a responsible human being
absolutely but I I mean I'm not a
babysitter either
I I think that is something that they or
he needs to figure out I don't know I
don't really know I don't really have to
say so that's the least of my words I'm
hoping that she does a good job and once
it comes out she changed her State of
Mind did she still signed to you
the way I see it is when you start doing
business without me it's none of my
business not me
so that's a bar it's at that point like
you want to do business without me okay
it's none of my business I'm not using
that one I'm not gonna fight with you
I'm definitely using that I'm not gonna
go call these people argue with nobody
no no no I'ma just go find some other
business right okay so when you hit like
okay all right is this is this obviously
you guys have genuine love for each
other she's your your day one you guys
have two children together right but how
much of this also is business
because you're putting music out here
yeah oh
it's all it's it's all business makes me
love me I think that I'm like a good
listener yeah like like I feel like I'm
a good listener like as far as like when
it comes to that side like he couldn't
tell me how to like change diaper or
something like that you're not just stay
in your lane but like as far as this I'm
like kind of like I want you to teach me
like I'm genuinely want to know like I
don't you know I don't know how to move
properly as far as stuff like that like
I I will listen and I'll be like okay
you know because actually
I'm gonna tell a story about you okay
okay so so he got locked up the day of
my music video oh so so the day yeah he
was supposed to go to court meet me at
my music video and I was supposed to be
in the video yeah so um so
when that when he called me and was like
I'm not gonna make it just make it lit
do what you got to do and I'm just kind
of like now you got to figure it out so
well that I've never I've never done a
music video I don't even know if I've I
don't even know if I've ever been to one
of his music videos from like to even
like watch see how it's supposed to be
done right like or how he talks to
people or moves yeah
but it was just me you and the camera
guy it wasn't kind of like it wasn't a
really like a production with like
several people and like girls like and
just like having to coordinate like you
know what I mean like so I just kind of
was like oh [__] but I felt like
I really didn't have a choice like make
it lit okay say less I'll make it lit so
then I showed up we actually I couldn't
even get to the house yet until I had to
message the people get into the house
because they didn't know what the [__]
was going on he wasn't answering the
phone it wasn't like I could be like
look this is what happened
I couldn't say that like that would have
looked so bad right so then I just kind
of was like look I just said he was on a
fool you got delayed delayed everybody
type shits yeah so type [__] so that's
such an easy excuse to get out of
everything right they're like [__]
it's okay I can't make it I got Coke bro
like you know so they they fell for it
and I just let them know like oh I'm
gonna make sure everything's straight so
there's like okay whatever so we go in
there I make sure it's all lit and I
don't even know what the point was but I
was just saying like he wanted me to
make a shirt happen so it happened and
Carter from jail gave her a couple
appointments yeah so I just kind of was
like okay let me do that and then
um there were certain things that he was
talking to me about prior to shooting
the video like oh we should do this or
we should do that so I made sure to
incorporate that you know so I'm
listening to everything he's saying
whether it's today and if we use it next
week like I'm still listening I wanna I
genuinely want to know right like I want
to learn like I don't know it seems like
you're kind of like a a big part of like
Zeus Network success and I can't imagine
that like their most successful show
being your guys's show they wouldn't
want to continue that if they wanted you
to be like is It season three now or two
if they were like hey Shawn out of here
let's get Jaden in here and let's run a
new season
of
Crazy in Love no I don't think we will
do it I don't think that it should be
yeah I want more music for her I'm just
saying I mean I think that if the bag
might be right now I mean if the bag is
ready but no money no no no no no no I
think that anything should be you not
like we're not saying no to no money but
we also got a vision you know and we
don't want to give like when we Google
her name you want the music to pop up
right to say American rapper I don't
want to say realities
personality model Super Love and Hip I
don't want to say nude I want to say
rapper so that's because that's what I
mean that's the that's the business I'm
in right
uh you know I did the only fast thing
and uh great but that's still under my
control I think you're more than like
music I think you're like what I'm
saying that's where my expertise is at
but I think you're awesome yeah like
you've mastered the internet bro like
yeah yeah like for music for music and
client reasons though so it's like music
incline but also just I just think
people are interested in you now man
me personally yeah me personally you're
a figure man like people just like
what's going my son's magic I told him I
don't know why he's nine I totally my
son literally said you're gonna go
interview blueface tell him I'm mad at
him I said why he's like he broke
rashawn's heart I said what the [__]
he's nine years old I totally agree I
totally agree but for me passing
something to somebody has got to be
music because that's like my expertise
you know I think you have a lot of other
expertise
you wear a lot of different hats bro I
blew up in a year like you blew up quick
off pure strictly my musically incline
I made everything about music in Arizona
is the first time you brought the mop
out on stage yeah bro my boy reposted
he's like this is the first I'm like I'm
just that seems like it was six months
ago but it was like four or five years
ago nah I'm better with Artistry bro
music is more of my Lane like of course
I can do anything now because I
succeeded at music but I took the music
to to get anywhere for me okay so me
doing that with her that's what I'm
gonna put I don't want to push
anything else